(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] You always look-
- [Shemar] What's up Kelly?
- Oh my gosh. You always look so good!
Like every time-
- Oh, thank you.
- Your style is so cool.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- I'm gonna need you to let me know
at some point where you got that sweater,
'cause I want it.
- Well, I'll tell you a story.
I'll tell you a story.
It's funny 'cause your peeps
backstage even gave me love
for-
- Yeah?
- For this little,
so this is the first time I
broke it out of the closet
and I've had it a little over a year.
So People magazine came to my house
and did like this little
in the life of Shemar Moore
and I'd just bought a new house,
and decorate and putting it all together.
- Yeah.
- And so they hired a stylist
to jazz me up, to have
me looking a certain,
you know-
- Yeah.
- Get me pimping for the photo shoot.
- Did they bring that.
- And so they brought
all these groovy clothes
and so everybody in my camp,
my homies and all, they're like
"Nah, that sweater ain't it,
that sweater ain't it."
- [Kelly] That sweater is it.
- And I used it in the photo shoot
and I was like, there's
something about it.
- Also like, the hippest,
Mr. Rogers vibe ever.
- There you go.
- Like I'm into it.
Yeah.
- Like you walked out and I was like,
I will own that at some point.
I'm gonna find it.
- I woke up this morning and, you know,
I woke up this morning, I was like,
okay, what am I gonna wear for Kelly?
I was like, all right, I got
this, I got this, I got this.
And then I looked up on the
shelf and I saw these shoes,
and they still had the price tag on them.
- You're like, I should
probably wear those.
- So I started, so I said,
okay, these jeans contrast.
I picked the shoes.
I was like, okay, what goes with shoes?
And I was like in my closet
going no, no, no, no.
Okay, I'm gonna rock the fedora.
And then the sweater
was just calling my name
and I was like, you know what?
Today's the day.
- I love that sweater!
(audience cheering)
It's a hit.
Do you enjoy like clothes and all that?
Do you enjoy fashion?
'Cause every time I see
you always look so sharp.
- Well, thank you.
I mean, I'm not Mr. Fashion Guy.
I just kind of,
I like shopping.
I mean, but I'll shop twice a year,
you know?
- Oh, yeah.
- Like, I'll just go big twice a year.
- That's me.
- And I got my little stores that I like.
- Yeah.
- And I'll go in
and go, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Okay, I'm good for six months.
I don't know if you're
allowed to say names.
I go to G-Star, I get all my jeans.
- Yeah, you like what you like.
- Up on sunset Boulevard's
place called a H. Lorenzo,
it's got a kind of European thing-
- Yeah.
- With their style.
I go there. I go to The Gap, get t-shirts.
- Love it, high, low, yeah.
- I'm a Calvin Klein underwear dude.
(Kelly gasping)
You know, like it's-
- I'm a Calvin Klein girl.
- There you go.
- Yeah.
I was like, we have this in common.
(audience cheering)
They're just comfortable is the thing.
And I like the band.
But wait, you've got "Sonic
the Hedgehog 2" out now.
- Yeah! Fun!
- I love the first one.
So what's happening in this
one and who are you playing?
- I play a character named Randall
and you know,
I spend my days play chasing bad guys.
you know, I'm tough guy, Hondo,
kicking down doors and chasing bad guys
and you know, I got the Hondo scowl.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so-
- That's intimidating.
- In this movie, I smile a
lot, I show all the pearlys,
I get to be goofy.
- Is that kind of fun to play?
Just such a different-
- Yeah.
I was actually a fish out of water.
So I was like, I don't know
if I'm doing a good job
because it's a cartoon.
Now, I played a real person
so I don't play a cartoon.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I play a real person, but
you're talking to tennis balls.
You know what I mean?
- Wait what?
- Well, 'cause Sonic is not really there.
- Well, obviously-
- Obviously.
- But you had to tennis ball?
- So they have a little
stick in the ground
with a tennis ball
and so you have to talk to the tennis ball
and then later in post,
they put in the cartoon.
So it was just so strange
talking to a tennis ball.
(audience laughing)
But I got to talk to human beings.
James Marsden,
one of the stars.
- Yeah. Oh I love Sonic.
I've seen the original a ton, my kids-
- Natasha Rothwell.
- Yeah.
- I get to play her kind of
sweetheart love interest and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Fiance thing, so there's a
lot of romantic, kissy vibe.
- Yeah.
- I'm not a big part of the movie
but it's a nice, sweet, little cameo
where I get to do my thing.
A lot of fun scenes with James Marsden.
There's a volleyball
scene that is hilarious.
But it was just,
I got to go to Hawaii.
I got to play golf.
I got to talk to tennis balls
- Oh my gosh.
- I got to-
- And there you go.
- And I got to be goofy fun
and to be part of a
franchise like that, it just-
- I was gonna say, we will see
this movie one billion times
in my house.
Like I've seen the first
one I can't even tell you
how many times.
- Well, my family, like, you know,
I'm kind of cool 'cause I was
on "Young and the Restless,"
I was on "Criminal Minds,"
and now I'm on "S.W.A.T."
- Yeah.
(audience cheering)
- But 28 years in the game,
I now have officially arrived-
- Yeah.
- In my family,
because I'm on Sonic the Hedgehog.
- No, it is the weirdest thing
I worked 20 years, right.
And then all of a sudden
the the coolest thing,
my kids are like, they're
like, "Yeah, you're all right."
And I worked with Arianna
Grande on "The Voice"
and like all of a sudden they're like,
"You know her?"
and I was like, wait, what?
- Wait, I'm somebody too.
Wait a minute-
- I was like,
"Yes I do. She's lovely. But what?"
I was like, that did it?
Out of all the things?
Anyway.